قبيله زياره بلينكن الى بكين البانتاجوني
يعلن تعقب من قاضي تجسس صيني في سماء
الولايات المتحده
الرئيس الصيني في تايوان ومن عواقب اي
صراع هناك
يهدد باندفاع ايران المتهور في برنامجها
النووي ويحذر طهران من عواقب وخيمه
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا الى هذه النشره المفصله
تاتيكم من العربيه
اعلنت وزاره الدفاع الامريكيه البانتاجون
انها تراقب منطاضا صينيا يعتقد يعتقد
اطلقته للتحليق فوق سماء الولايات المتحده
بهدف التجسس وقلا مسؤول امريكي ان المنطاد
الصيني هدفه التجسس وجمع المعلومات
الاستخباراتيه مضيفا ان واشنطن كانت تتعقب
المنطاد منذ دخوله المجال الجوي للولايات
المتحده قبل يومين وتفحصته عن قرب من خلال
طائرات عسكريه امريكيه وقد اوصى كبار
القاده العسكريين الامريكيين بعدم اسقاط
بالون التجسس الصيني فوق مونتانا بسبب
مخاطر السلامه المحتمله من الحطم
[موسيقى]
قضيه المنطاد واحده من التحديات التي
ستواجه زياره بلينكن الى بكين الاسبوع
المقبل لبحث
للبحث مع نظير صيني ملفات مهمه بينها
الازمه في تايوان وسجلات حول الرقائق
والتجاره الدوليه وذلك وسط تسريبات تتحدث
عن ان الوزيرين سيحاولان التركيز حول
كيفيه تجنب اكبر اقتصادين في العالم حربا
بارده جديده رغم توتر العلاقات بين واشنطن
وبيكين
حضر مدير وكاله المخابرات المركزيه
من ان الصين تمثل اكبر تحد جيوسياسي يواجه
الولايات المتحده وقال انه من الخطا
التقليل من خطوره العلاقات الصينيه
الروسيه مؤكدا ان الرئيس الصيني متفاجئ
ومصدوم من ضعف قدرات الجيش الروسي وحول
صراع في تايوان قال ويليام بانه سيكون له
عواقب وخيمه على جميع الاطراف ويجب عدم
التقليل من طموحات الرئيس الصيني للسيطره
على تايوان والتعامل معها بجديه وكشف مدير
المخابرات او وكاله المخابرات المركزيه ان
الرئيس الصيني يواجه الكثير من المشكلات
الداخليه في بلاده
من جانبه اكد وزير الخارجيه الروسي ان
روسيا لا تتعمد انشاء تحالفات عسكريه مع
الصين مضيفا انه رغم ذلك فالعلاقات
الروسيه الصينيه في افضل حالاتها ولا يوجد
ملفات محظوره للنقاش
على الرغم من حقيقه اننا لا ننشئ تحالفا
عسكريا مع الصين فان علاقاتنا افضل مع
التحالفات العسكريه التقليديه وليس لها اي
حدود ولا توجد مواضيع محظوره انها في
الواقع افضل مقارنه بكل سنوات وجود
الاتحاد السوفيتي وجمهوريه الصين الشعبيه
والاتحاد الروسي
اعتراف واضح وصريح من كييف بصعوبه الوضع
وتقدم روسيا في الجبهه الشرقيه بل وتحضير
الاخيره ايضا لهجوم محتمل كبير محللون
رجحوا ان الهجوم الروسيه القادم سيكون
الاكبر منذ بدايه الحرب وفقا لصحيفه
نيويورك تايمز الامريكيه تقرير الصحيفه
الغربيه اضاف ايضا ناموسكو قد تستعد لفتح
جبهه جديده حيث تسعى لتقدم قوتها عبر
الحدود الروسيه لاستعاده الاراضي التي
طردت منها في سومي اوخركيف بشمال شرق
اوكرانيا في حين تتاهب كييف للصد سيما في
ظل معلومات انا موسكو تحشد نحو نصف مليون
جندي على الحدود وتكثف قصفها قبل ان تصل
الدبابات والعربات المدرعه وانظمه الاسلحه
الاخرى من الغرب الى اوكرانيا
بعد فرنسا انضمت بريطانيا الى قائمه دول
التي لا تستبعد وامداد اوكرانيا بطائرات
مقاتله وزير الدفاع البريطاني قال انه لا
يستبعد امدادكياف بطائرات مقاتله لكنه
اعتبر انها لن تكون عصا سحريه تغير مسار
الحرب موسكو لم تخفي قلقها من دخول اسلحه
الغرب المتطوره الى اقرب نقطه لها لاسيما
مع الزخم الاخير في الدعم العسكري لكن
يبدو ان اكثر ما يثير خشيه الروس هي
دبابات
الامريكيه الالمانيه عفوا والتي اوشكت على
الوصول وتحدث عنها بوتين بشكل صريح في
كلمته بمناسبه ذكرى 80 لمعركه ستالينبرغ
واتهم ايضا الغربي اعاده القتال في
اوكرانيا بايدي خلفاء هتلر عبر هذه
الدبابات قائلا لدينا ما نرد به على
ارسالها الى كييف
القلق الروسي لن يتوقف على الدبابات
فالغرب احتضن كياف بشكل اكبر ومساعدته
العسكريه زادت وفي جديدها ان فرنسا قررت
تزويد اوكرانيا بانظمه رادار للدفاع الجوي
لتتبع الصواريخ والطائرات بدون طيار
القادمه من المنطقه او في المنطقه المحيطه
بالعاصمه الاوكرانيه وزير الدفاع
الاوكراني اوليكسي
وصف نظام الرادار جراوند ماستر 200 بانه
فعال للغايه وانه سينقذ ارواح الاوكرانيين
اعلنت رئيسه المفوضيه الاوروبيه ان
الاتحاد الاوروبي يعتزموا انشاء مركز
تنسيق في مدينه لاهاي الهولنديه لجمع ادله
لمحاكمه روسيا بسبب النزاع في اوكرانيا
مضيفه انه سيتم انشاء مركز دولي في ذات
المدينه الهولنديه للتحقيق في الجرائم في
اوكرانيا على حد وصفها
طلب اعضاء في الكونغرس الامريكيه الرئيس
جو بايدن بربط بيع مقاتلات لتركيا او
مقاتلات اف 16 لتركيا بالسماحي لانضمام
فنلندا والسويد لحلف النيتو بسبب عدم وضوح
موقفي انقره من انضمام الدولتين
الاوروبيتين للنيتو وكان الرئيس التركي
رجب طيب اردوغان قد طالب الولايات المتحده
بتنفيذ وعدها وتسليم انقره طائرات اف 16
و1535 محذرا من ان هناك مقابلا للتصرفات
الامريكيه
في ذات السياق قالت رئيسه الوزراء
الفناديه سانا مارين ان فنلندا والسويد
قدمتان طلبا للانضمام الى النيتو
اعتقد انه من المهم جدا ان نرسل اليوم
رساله واضحه فنلندا والسويد قدمتها طلبا
معا ومن مصلحه الجميع ان ننضم الى
نحن على اتصال وثيق جدا بشكل يومي بهذا
الشان فنلندا والسويد الصوفيان كل ما يلزم
للحصول على العضويه بالطبع نريد من تركيا
والمجر ايضا التصديق على طلبينا في اقرب
وقت ممكن وبالطبع نحن على اتصال وثيق جدا
بهذا الشان انا
برلمانيون من 20 دوله بينها بريطانيا
واوكرانيا و جورجيا وايسلندا وكندا عن
رغبه في حظر مشاركه الوفد الروسي في
اجتماعي منظمه الامن والتعاون في اوروبا
المقرر عقده نهايه الشهر الجارينا وكتب
النواب في رساله الى السلطات في النمسا ان
مشاركه الوفد في مثل هذا الوقت من شانه ان
يرسل اشاره خاطئه الى المجتمع الدولي
ويعتبر استفزازا واضحا
نشرتنا مستمره مشاهدينا وفيها بعد قليل
توافق بين الخرطوم وتل ابيب لتطبيع
العلاقات
اهلا بكم من جديد
ندى الرئيس الفرنسي باندفاع ايران المتهور
في تطوير برنامجها النووي مؤكدا انه اذا
استمر ستكون له عواقب لا محاله خاصه مع
افتقار ايران للشفافيه تجاه الوكاله
الدوليه للطاقه الذريه
الشديد اذا انشطه ايران المزعزعه
للاستقرار في المنطقه باسرها مشيرا الى ان
الدعم الايراني للعدوان الروسي في
اوكرانيا عرض ايران للعقوبات والعزله
المتزايده
زعيم المعارضه الاسرائيليه يا ايلابيد
اعتبر ان استراتيجيه ايران في المرحله
الحاليه تتمثل في الاستمرار في تصعيد
التهديد الذي تشكله ولكن بطريقه تدريجيه
بحسب صحيفه جيروسليم بوست ويرجح ان تتجه
ايران لاختبار اراده الغرب العام المقبل
عبر تخصيب كميه صغيره من اليورانيوم الى
مستوى 90% ما يمكن استخدامه في صنع
الاسلحه النوويه مستبعدا قيام طهران
بتطوير سلاح نووي واضاف العبيد ان
استراتيجيه طهران هذه تهدف الى تجنب اي رد
فعل كبير على حد قوله
اخر حول الاوضاع المتازمه هناك بسبب
الاحتجاجات الشعبيه قال مدير وكاله
المخابرات المركزيه الامريكيه قال ان
الحكومه الايرانيه اصبحت غير مستقره بشكل
متزايد بسبب ما يحدث داخل البلاد مشيرا
الى شجاعه من وصفهن بالنساء الايرانيات
اللاي سئمنا الانتهاكات واعمال العنف
والقمع
طلبت بريطانيا واستراليا ايران بوقف اعدام
المتظاهرين وقمع الاحتجاجات كما اذان
البلدان في بيان مشترك توفير طهران اسلحه
لروسيا وتعهد وزراء الخارجيه والدفاع في
البلدين بمواجهه مساله توفير ايران لاصلحه
تساعد روسيا في حربها على اوكرانيا واتفق
الوزراء على مواصله العمل مع الشركاء
الدوليين لمحاسبه ايران من خلال وسائل
تشمل العقوبات
نقلا عن مواقع اعلاميه محليه ان النظام
الايراني امر بتحليق مروحيه عسكريه فوق
عدد من المساجد في زهدان وذلك وسط انباء
عن تجديدات امنيه بعد اعتقال مستشار خطيب
الجمعه واضافت ان القوات الامنيه
الايرانيه كثفت حمله الاعتقالات العشوائيه
في منطقه زهدان خوفا من اتساع رقعه
الاحتجاجات المشتعله في البلاد منذ سبتمبر
الماضي
اعلنت وزاره الخارجيه السودانيه لاتفاق مع
اسرائيل على المضي قدما في تطبيع العلاقات
بين البلدين واقلب يانون للوزارين وزير
الخارجيه علي الصادق التقى نظيره
الاسرائيلي اليكون في الخرطوم حيث تم
الاتفاق على تطوير علاقات البلدين في
مجالات الزراعه والطاقه والصحه والمياه
والتعليم واضافت الخارجيه السودانيه انه
تم حذف اسرائيل على العمل على تحقيق
الاستقرار والسلام للشعب الفلسطيني
من جانبه قال وزير الخارجيه الاسرائيليه
ان زيارته للسودان ترسل اسس لاتفاق سلام
تاريخي وخلال مؤتمر صحفي عقب عودته من
الخرطوم اكد كون ان اتفاق السلام مع
السودان سيعزز الاستقرار الاقليمي والامن
القومي لاسرائيل فيما اوضحت وزاره
الخارجيه الاسرائيليه انه من المنتظر
توقيع الاتفاق او اتفاق السلام مع السودان
هذا العام في واشنطن بعد تشكيل حكومه
مدنيه
الخرطوم عاصمه السودان حيث قررت الدول
العربيه فيها اللاءات الثلاث التاريخيه لا
سلام مع اسرائيل لم فوضت مع اسرائيل
والاعتراف باسرائيل نحن نبني واقعا جديدا
مع السودانيين تصبح فيه
نعم للمفاوضات بين اسرائيل والسودان نعم
للاعتراف باسرائيل ونعم للسلام بين الدول
والشعوب
ذكرت وسائل اعلامنا امريكيه نقلا عن مصادر
مطلعه انه من المتوقع ان يجري مكتبه
تحقيقات الفيدرالي تفتيشا لمنزل مايك بانس
نائب الرئيس الامريكي السابق في انديانا
ومكتبه في واشنطن العاصمه بحثا عن سجلات
سريه وعقلت صحيفه ان وزاره العدل تتواصل
مع الفريق القانوني لباس لتحديد موعد
لتفتيش منزله في انديانا وربما ايضا مكتبه
في واشنطن
وقعت السعوديه وفرنسا مذكره تفاهم لوضع
اطار للتعاون في قطاع الطاقه وتشجيعه بين
البلدين وزير الطاقه السعوديه الامير عبد
العزيز بن سلمان بن عبد العزيز بحث مع
وزيره الخارجيه الفرنسيه
للطاقه الذريه والفرص المستقبليه في مختلف
مجالات الطاقه افادت وكاله الانباء
السعوديه ان مذكره تعاون في مجال الطاقه
بين فرنسا والسعوديه تتناول مجالات
التعاون في التحول الرقمي وتوطين المواد
والمنتجات والخدمات المتعلقه بقطاعات
الطاقه وسلاسل الامداد
في اول زياره لمسؤول رفيع المستوى يمثل
المملكه العربيه السعوديه بعد تشكيل حكومه
السوداني اختتم الامير فيصل بن فرحان
زياره وصفت بالمهمه الى العاصمه بغداد
التقى فيها نظيره العراقي والرئاسات
الثلاث من جانبنا نحن نرحب بشركات
السعوديه
وبالاستثمار السعودي في العراق بهذه
العبارات استقبل وزير الخارجيه العراقي
نظيره السعودي في بغداد في اول زياره
لمسؤول رفيع المستوى من المملكه العربيه
السعوديه بعد تشكيل حكومه السوداني نعمل
معا
لتخفيض حاله التوتر التوتر في المنطقه
والسعوديه كدوله
ودوله قاعده
في الاطار الاسلامي
تلعب دورا مهما في هذا المجال والعراق
كدوله محوريه في هذه المنطقه
نعمل معا
لتخفيف هذه التوترات الموجوده في المنطقه
وحل المشاكل عن طريق السلميه وعن طريق
الحوار ملفات الامن والاقتصاد والطاقه
تصدرت اجنده اللقاءات علاقات ثنائيه
متميزه مع المملكه هكذا تصفها بغداد مع
تاكيد واضح من الجانبين على خفض التوتر في
المنطقه من خلال الحوار مع جميع الاطراف
وانا اعمل سويا
بتنسيق وثيق مع معاليكم لدفع عمليه
الاستقرار في المنطقه من خلال الحوار ومن
خلال
تعزيز المصالح المشتركه
معالجه اي اوجه خلاف وهذا مهم جدا لان لا
بدون اقرار لن نستطيع ان نحقق الرخاء الذي
نسى اليه زياره الامير فيصل بن فرحان الى
بغداد شملت ايضا الرئاسات الثلاث المتمثله
برئيس الجمهوريه ورئيس البرلمان اضافه الى
رئيس الحكومه جرى التاكيد من خلالها على
تطوير الشراكه الثنائيه وتوسعه الاجتماعات
من خلال مجلس التنسيق العراقي السعودي وحل
المشاكل العالقه في المنطقه من خلال
الحوارات الثنائيه سامر الكبيسي العربيه
بغداد
في الملف العراقي ايضا وبعد ضربه انخفاض
العمله العراقيه امام الدولار ضرب اخرى في
صميم الاقتصاد العراقي حيث تداول
العراقيون تحضيرات من انتشار عمله مزيفه
من فئه 25 الف دينار في السوق في منطقه
الاستخبارات او القت الاستخبارات القبض
على متهمين قاموا بتزييف وتهريب العمله
فلنتابعه كميه ضخمه من المزور موجوده
بالسوق
الدينار العراقي لا ثقه فيه عراقيون
يشككون في الاموال منه المزور بدقه عاليه
والاخر سهل الكشف فئه الخمسه والعشرين الف
دينار منتشره في السوق مزوره ومتداوله
العراقيون استفاقوا على المحظور تحذيرات
من فخ التزوير وغيرها فيديوهات تعليميه
لكشف التزوير النجمه شايفين
يطلع عندك كلمه العراق اذا طلعت كلمه
العراق هاي تعتبر مو مزوره
ذهول في مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي الدينار
بين التزييف وتخفيض قيمته امام الدولار
واتهامات لايران بتورطها في ذلك عبر
اذرعها في العراق الاطار هرب الدولار
هاشتاج وجد فيه عراقيون مساحه للتعبير عن
السخط والسخريه مستشار الحكومه العراقيه
نفى للعربيه ما هو متداول عن تزييف العمله
مشككا في صحه الاخبار فيما اكد ان ما
يدوره هو محاولات فقط لافتعال الازمات
واثاره الشارع العراقي غيداء السالم
العربيه
صوت الجمهوريون في مجلس النواب الامريكي
على عزل النائبه الديمقراطيه الهام عمر من
لجنه الشؤون الخارجيه محققين فوزا لرئيس
المجلس هذا المقاعد والذي تعاهد منذ فتره
طويله باقصاء عمر ووافق المجلس على القرار
باغلبيه 2018 صوتا مقابل 211 معارضا
وتصويت نائب واحد بحاضر
الجمهوريون في مجلس النواب الامريكي يقصون
النائبه الديمقراطيه الهام عمر من لجنه
الشؤون الخارجيه بتهمه معادتها للساميه
التصويت جاء بعد نقاش حامد خلاله
الديمقراطيون الجمهوريين بالنفاق
والعنصريه وبزدواجيه المعايير لوجود اعضاء
منهم استخدموا ايضا عبارات تعتبر معاديه
للساميه ولم يحاسبوا فيما القت عمر خطاب
الدفاعيا عن نفسها
[تصفيق]
رئيس مجلس النواب كمان
باغلبيه مقاعد مجلس النواب
وكان منكر في اعلن تامين عدد اصوات كافيه
لاستبعاد عمر واكد بعد عزلها انها لا يجب
ان تكون عضوا في اللجنه بسبب تصريحاتها
واضاف ان الجمهوريين لا يقصونها عن باقي
اللجان
فيما يتعلق بالنائب عمر ما قالته من
التعليقات المعاديه للساميه وان الجيش في
امريكا يساوي حماس وطالبان وانه في الحادي
عشر من سبتمبر حدث شيء ما في ذلك اليوم
حتى الرئيس الديمقراطي السابق للجنه يعتقد
ان تعليقاتها كانت خاطئه
الديمقراطيون التهموا سابقا الجمهوريين
بانهم يريدون رد الكيل بمكيالين لطردهم
عضوين جمهوريين عندما الاغلبيه في المجلس
معتبرين ان التحرك لطرد النائبين
الديمقراطيين ادم شافو اريكس والويل من
لجنه المخابرات اضافه الى طرد عمر عملا
انتقاميا سياسيا حسين الطولد العربيه
واشنطن
موقع بيزنس ان منصه انستقرام
يقضون وقتا اكبر في التصفح مما يهدد
مكانتها ويقلل من نسبه الارباح التي
تحققها وذكر الموقع انستجرام الذي يحقق
عائدات اعلانات تقدر بنحو 43 مليار دولار
اصبح معرض للتهديد من قبل تيك توك فيما
اظهرت استطلاعات مركز بايو للابحاث ان
نسبه المراهقين الذين يتصفحون تيك توك
بشكل دائم كانت اعلى بنسبه 50% من
انستجرام
بعد عامل على حادثه رحيل الطفل المغربي
ريان في اقليم شفشاون بالمغرب اثرى سقوطه
في البئر عاده الافراح اخيرا الى بيت اسره
الطفل الراحل باعلان قدوم مولود ذكر
للعائله ففي المستشفى المحلي في مدينه
تطوان في شمال المغرب وضعت الام وسيمه
خرشيش طفلها وكان طفل المغربي الراحل ريان
سقط في بئر ضيق على عمق اثنين وثلاثين
مترا قرب منزل اسرته في الاول من شهر
فبراير من العام الماضي وهو الحادث الذي
شد انذار وقلوب العالم
هذا تكريما لذكرى ريان تعرض العربيه
الفيلم الوثائقي اثر الفراشه يوم الاحد
المقبل الخامس من فبراير في تمام التاسعه
والنصف بتوقيت السعوديه والسابعه والنصف
بتوقيت المغرب الفيلم من انتاج وحده
الانتاج الوثائقي في العربيه ويعود الى
مسقط راس الطفل ويكشف المزيد من التفاصيل
ختام هذه النشره الى العناوين
قبيله زياره بلينكن الى بكين البنداجوني
يعلن تعقبا من طرد تجسس صيني في سماء
الولايات المتحده
سي اي اي تحذر من طموحات الرئيس الصيني في
تايوان ومن عواقب اي صراع هناك
دفاع ايران المتهور في برنامجها النووي
ويحذر طهران من عواقب وخيمه
[موسيقى]